hätte es auch noch früher aufmachen
können was willst du willst überhaupt
von mir ich bin halt deine wohnung
angucken
du darfst reinkommt staaten anders
aussehen
deswegen habe ich doch extra die
allerdings machte und damit etwas gehen
ab ohne herz bekommen
zu allen neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut jetzt hier sicherlich
schon mitbekommen ich bin umgezogen
waren alleine vor circa einem monat und
wohne hier in meiner neuen wohnung habe
eigentlich alles soweit eingerichtet
also auf jeden fall ist die wohnung auf
dem stand von maja was ja der fein stück
muss auch gemacht werden aber die
wohnung ist auf einem stand wo man sie
auf jeden fall zeigen kann deswegen auf
mich zu sagen alex macht das immer so
leute dass er die unnötigsten sachen als
erstes rein nimmt und die wichtigsten
sachen wie zum beispiel ein küchentisch
wir gleich sehen werdet kommt also
wahrscheinlich erst in einem jahr
ich brauche keinen küchentisch wir gehen
einfach mal los wodurch starten
vielleicht bei deiner schuhsammlung ja
hier sind also das ist auch noch ein
bisschen provisorische hier sieht man ja
wir haben jetzt eine pappe 1 abtrete die
schuhe sind jetzt auch überhaupt nicht
heftig man denkt jetzt soll die trasse
schuhe aber das sind andere schule ist
eine abstellkammer oder oder auch maries
schlacht machen oder auch franziska
barth das und vielleicht kurz grund zur
aufteilung ich habe hier auch auf dem
alex hauptkanal schon mal eine kleinere
tour gemacht so allerdings war da nichts
drin eigentlich da ist mein schlafzimmer
hier ist das büro und hier ist das
wohnzimmer wir starten muss beim
schlafzimmer oder mehr kommen wir
starten ein wohnzimmer kommen verkehr
irland hier rein was ich
heuer ist diese tür gebracht ja alles
weg irgendwie sondern regt die wohnung
noch viel größer direkt du darfst
eintreten wird ja einer gruppierung
licht angemacht
das ist meine couch dieses super nice
und dann haben wir hier meinen neuen
fernseher den habt war ich habe mich so
gefreut über den fernseher
leg dich mal einer vor bitte wir hatten
diagonale von 1 meter 90 da kann ich
sogar im fussball drauf gucken weil ihr
bisher im fußballdress
und vielleicht mal so die verhältnisse
abzuchecken tonne heißt oder der wälder
also was eigentlich das beste an der
wohnung was aber auch super neiße wir
gehen mal hierhin ist dieses tablet
ich habe mir nämlich einen tempel
angebracht und zwar bevor die wohnung
immer mehr und mehr über dieses tablet
zu steuern und was das meiste ist das
tablet mir freundlicherweise vom bag
market zur verfügung gestellt der coole
internetseite auf der er auf jeden fall
richtig sein wenn es um wie vor wird ich
zeige euch die mal eben und erkläre ich
dass da ein bisschen und dann machen wir
weiter mit dem rest der wohnung ja leute
wir befinden uns die gerade auf der
seite bookmarken es eigentlich alles was
mit technik zu tun hat sei es jetzt
computer vision geräte irgendwelche
spiele konsolen controller smartphones
alles mögliche und das beste daran ist
alle produkte sind rief er ist also
wieder aufbereitet sag ich mal wieder
aufbereitete produkte haben eigentlich
nur vorteile sie sind günstiger als wenn
man sie neu für die umwelt ist das super
gut weil das gerät wird nicht neu
produziert sondern einfach nur noch mal
wieder ein bisschen aufgefrischt und an
sich hat man aber trotzdem ein voll
funktionsfähiges neues gerät ich zeige
euch hier mal kurz das ipad und den
controller den ich vom bag marke
bekommen ab ok ich denke mal hier ist
das ipad drin
und hier kann der controller ich wohl
mal kurzen messer dann machen wir das
leute ich mach das mal kurz an er
wirklich mega nice hier schaut euch an
also danke auf jeden fall dafür und
jetzt kommen wir noch zum kassenführer
sind natürlich auch noch bei uns laden
und jetzt wird natürlich noch der
controller auf gemacht jetzt haben wir
es sieht echt sehr nice aus liegt gut in
der hand und ich habe meinen job perfekt
kann ich wieder bisschen spielen weniger
falsche motto weniger müll und günstiger
beck market ist auf jeden fall der
marktführer in europa wer irdisch
fordert hier kann es noch mal gut sehen
wir haben smartphones tablets macbook
apple watch ein weg fotografie
staubsauger lautsprecher oder alle
produkte die natürlich nur von experten
wieder aufbereitet oder honig vermischt
werden für bis zu 70 prozent günstiger
wir haben zum beispiel ein iphone l 64 4
671 euro anstatt 89 euro oder dieses
dreislar macbook pro für 699 euro wenn
ihr mit youtube anfangen wollte gibt es
auch eine menge kamera ist hier die
canon eos 1000d für 207 also nur der
buddy die hatte ich sogar auch mal am
anfang meiner youtube laufbahn und was
noch ganz wichtiges zu sagen habt auf
alle produkte 36 monate garantie ich
verlinke beck war wird ganz oben in der
beschreibung geht gerne drauf ich habe
euch ein bisschen rum und vielleicht ist
ja was für euch dabei ok herzlich
willkommen zurück ich zeige euch jetzt
mal eben mit welchen sache nicht schon
angefangen also wie gesagt smartphone
mäßig und so wird sich das so viel krass
entwickeln wir machen das tablet einfach
mal an einsperren das also ich muss
sagen das sieht auf dieser wand doch
absolut genial oder wunderschön ich habe
zum beispiel schon zwei lampen
integrierte kann man dann hier über
steuern wie die zum beispiel ist doch
die kann auch so fraktionen so die hansa
musik spielen das mache ich mir da wird
das aufgebot wird auch darüber los brach
der frau
ich brauche jetzt aber gar nicht und im
büro mal auf lampen aber das kommt jetzt
alles so nach und nach da könnt ihr euch
sehr darauf freuen da mache ich seit
auch videos zu ja die küche noch gar
nicht gezeigt da bin ich auch sehr stolz
drauf weil man sagen muss ich hatte nie
mehr küche also zumindest eine die
wirklich funktioniert kann man hier an
machen und dann leuchtet das ihr so
schön ich bin nicht selbst so handlich
habe ich will das auch immer sehr
unauthentisch wenn im winter ihre
wohnung zeigen die absolut sauber ist
und da gar nichts steht ja danke wir
haben hier doch eine spülmaschine die
spülmaschine ich mache jeden tag die
spieler schon gefolgt muss nichts machen
sonst musste ich immer selber spielen
absolut bisschen schwer zu zeigen wir
gehen mal kurz auf dem balkon hier auch
cool hier der sonnenschirm ist alles
noch ein bisschen provisorisch leute ich
rauche nicht das ist alles das werk
meiner freunde so sieht das hier aus
will ein bisschen aufpassen dass man
nicht so viel sehen und hier kommt auch
noch so eine lounge ecke hin oder sonne
sonne liege also seine schwebe liege ich
weiß gar nicht wie das heißt also hat
man auf jeden fall mehr als genug platz
das ist sehr geil also wenn ich das mit
köln vergleiche man da hatte ich so
einen mini balkon und hier kannst du
fußball spielen was okay das war jetzt
übertrieben okay dann gehen wir wieder
rein sagt sack für uns geht es morgen
und wohl auch deswegen stellt ihren
koffer und mein zimmer was ich euch
jetzt zeigen werde
ist auch nicht so mega knie wie ich
thomas keil der fernsehapparat
angebracht wird mir jetzt haben wir hier
auch noch einen fernseher und schwebe
die mit
dann haben wir hier kleiderschrank habe
ich jetzt erst mal provisorisch
eingebaut sondern mini kleider spannend
also die kommt auf jeden fall noch ein
großer kleiner schon hin ja also ist
jetzt nichts spektakuläres logisch ist
halt märz normales zimmer ein
jugendzimmer kanada nicht soweit und ab
ins büro das ist mein lieblingsort ein
recht weil ich da mit super entspannt
kommen sie bitte mit hier gehen wir rein
und machen mal die tür hinter mir
zumachen schild hängen englische hier
kommen noch mehr leds ein
und ich habe noch sechs da hinten liegen
brauchst jetzt nicht filmen die kommen
auch noch an die wand dann kommen wir
noch so kabelkanäle denn damit halt
einfach kliem weiß aussieht hier habe
ich noch so eine kleine sitzecke kann
man sich hinstellen wenn es das habe ich
in unterschiedlich aufgebaut das ist
meine bedingung sei von 11 gegen uns
hier wohl hier
das ist so gut weil meine ist kaputt
gegangen
du kannst ja mal ein bisschen zurück
gehen wir haben dann auf jeden fall hier
noch die aufnahme ecke und ja also kann
man mit elektrisch verstellen das ist
sehr naiv weil du kannst auch das im
stehen arbeiten und hier fühle ich mich
wirklich sehr wohl habe ich mir so eine
kleine notiz ecke gemacht da kann ich
immer drauf schreiben was ich an dem tag
so zu tun hab das hilft sehr kann ich
jedem eigentlich empfehlen das zu machen
irgendwann ich das gesehen und dafür
nicht machen ansonsten fehlt noch
irgendwie konnte ich das denn jetzt
vergessen
vielleicht werde dann die rein gehst du
durch beide die ich nie weg ja was hält
man gibt es in der lampe ja ja aber mit
mir in montiert naja darüber licht sonst
hat man das
das hier ist die dusche supercool also
die dusche gefällt mir sehr und ja ihr
seid ein kein großes bad aber es reicht
also ich glaube ich haben wir schöne
also ich glaube das sind insgesamt schon
fast 100 quadratmeter die ich hier zur
verfügung hat ich glaube 7 1936 deswegen
ich bin sehr zufrieden und ich hoffe ihr
hattet mit coolen einblicke könnt ihr
bei eurem wagen in die kommentare
schreiben
was ihr noch ändern würde und daraus ihr
ergänzen würde einiges kommt auf jeden
fall noch und ich zeige euch dann
natürlich wenn etwas weltbewegendes
neues gibt halt hier in der wohnung war
gestern auf jeden fall nicht um in der
video strombeck market abzuchecken geht
auf die seite und schaut euch da gerne
ein bisschen um wir sehen uns dann am
mittwoch wieder gibt's neues video jetzt
mal mittwochs und sonntags das was von
mir
haut rein banken marie für film und